[MUSIC PLAYING]
- From around the eighth to
the late fourth centuries BCE,
the Greek world consisted
of around 1000 city-states
concentrated in the southern
Balkan Peninsula and the Aegean
and spread over the coastlands
of the Mediterranean and Black
Seas.
In these centuries, the Archaic
and Classical periods that have
been canonized as
Greek civilization,
this network of city-states
was characterized by a close
relationship with a sea, a
fierce insistence on local
autonomy, and a complicated
interaction with a powerful,
dominant, non-Greek imperial
state of the Near East--
Egypt, Babylonia, and from
the sixth century, the Persian
Empire.
This all changed
suddenly in 334 BCE
when Alexander the Great,
the young king of Macedonia,
steered his flagship across the
Hellespont and from its prow,
threw a spear onto
the beach of Troy.
With this symbolic
act of invasion--
a deliberate emulation
of the Homeric heroes--
he launched his
campaign of conquest
across the Near East,
North Africa, Central Asia
and northern India.
Alexander's campaign is one of
the best understood and most
densely studied moments
in all antiquity.
And it has been turned, in some
complex and often pernicious
ways, into the archetypal
case of the European man going
east of the triumphal and
heroic conquest of Hellenism
over a supine Asia.
Yet conqueror of the
world though he was,
Alexander failed to
sire a male heir--
an adult male heir.
And as a result,
in a civil war that
lasted more than a
generation, his vast empire
broke into three
great powers ruled
by lines of kings descending
from his generals.
These offer the
ancient historian
three usefully
different scenarios
of Greco-Macedonian imperialism.
In Macedonia,
Alexander's own homeland,
we find the Antigonid
Kingdom, shown in red.
This was basically a
monocultural, Hellenic sphere,
its kings slotting
themselves into
the long institutional
tradition of Macedonian
national monarchy.
In Egypt, yellow, the
Ptolemaic Dynasty,
running from Ptolemy I to
the famous Cleopatra VII,
this dynasty ruled the
bicultural, Janus-faced kingdom
of Greeks and Egyptians
centered on the new capital
of Alexandria.
And its rulers worked
to fit themselves
into the ancient pharaonic
paradigm of kingship.
And finally, the kingdom which
is my focus, the Seleucid
Empire, in green, multicultural
or, perhaps better,
hydra-headed.
Over the course of the
second and first centuries
BCE, each of these
kingdoms would
be defeated by the expansion
of the Roman Republic,
relentless as a tectonic plate--
first Macedonia, then
Asia, finally Egypt.
The historical period of
these three great kingdoms
is known as the Hellenistic Age.
It's one of the most thrilling
moments in all ancient history.
From the perspective
of classics,
the spatial frame
of Greek history
suddenly and rapidly
explodes from the coastlands
of the Mediterranean to
Central Asia, the Sudan, India,
and the borders of China.
Near Eastern history
and Greek history
become the same project.
There's a greater
urgency to all forms
of cultural and
intellectual interaction
between the Greek world
and former neighbors-- now
subjects.
The dominant form
of Greek government
becomes territorial monarchy,
not city-state democracy.
And for the first
time, Greek history
becomes a true history
of empire, that is,
of a spatially extensive rule
over non-Greek populations
and all that follows from this.
At its height in the third
and early second centuries,
the Seleucid Empire
extended from Central Asia
to Bulgaria, from Armenia to
Bahrain before expanding down
the Levantine coast at the
beginning of the second century
BCE, when it lost its eastern
and western peripheries.
It had two basic
characteristics from which
its forms of statecraft and
claims to legitimacy descend.
First, most obviously, an
extraordinary linguistic,
religious, and social diversity.
So from the great Iranosphere
in the east of kind of Central
Asia, Persia, Mesopotamia--
fabulously fertile--
much of our evidence
comes from here.
Anatolia, including
important Greek city-states
on its western coast,
and eventually also
the Levant, so Lebanon, Israel,
the Palestinian territories.
Second foundational
characteristic,
and quite a bizarre one,
actually, the Seleucid kingdom
was ruled by a dynasty
and an imperial elite who
came from Greece and
Macedonia, who spoke Greek
and who privileged
Hellenic cultural forms.
Yet the Greco-Macedonian
homeland
lay outside the
kingdom's territories.
It was a kind of imperialism
of diaspora, which is
hard to find a close parallel.
It would be like imagining
British India without Britain.
What I want to suggest today
is that this double situation--
on the one hand a confrontation
with cultural multiplicity
and the sense of arbitrariness
that follows, and on the other,
the disembeddedness of
this imperial elite,
the fact of being sundered
from all the traditional forms
and claims of the
Greco-Macedonian homeland--
generated forms of statecraft
that tended toward abstraction
to a degree otherwise
unparalleled
in the ancient world.
In my first book,
as Judy mentioned,
I explored how this worked
at a spatial level--
things like grid-planned
cities, road building,
and measurements, geographic
exploration, and science.
This afternoon, I'll
introduce some ideas
on Seleucid time
reckoning, which
is the focus of my current
book project, which
is the new working title,
Time and Its Adversaries
in the Seleucid Empire.
Now I accept that chronology
and dating may not
seem the most
exciting of things,
but they're the stuff
that history is made on.
In two respects they
turn the past historical.
Dates allow things
to happen only once.
And dates insist on the
ordering and interrelation
of all happenings.
An event must be chained
to its place in time
before it becomes
an available object
for historical articulation.
And the modes by which we
apprehend such historical time
frame how we experience our
present, conceive a future,
remember the past,
reconcile with impermanence,
and make sense of a world far
wider, older, and more enduring
than any of us.
Today, almost
everyone in the world
thinks of the passage of
historical time in these terms,
and it will sound
completely obvious.
This year is 2018, last year was
2017, next year will be 2019.
We're confident that a
century ago it was 1918,
and in a 1,000 years, it
will be 3018, if there's
anyone left to name it.
All of us are fluent
with these years.
We're used to writing
them everywhere.
As a child, I used to line up
my pennies by year of minting,
and now I carefully note
dates of publication
in my scholarship.
Year numbers are ubiquitous.
I'm going to ask you to
imagine a world without such
a numbered timeline.
I think it may be
ultimately impossible
for us to sort of inhabit such
a world, but we should try.
Because before the
Seleucid Empire,
historical time, the
publican annual marking
of the passage of years, was
measured in only three ways--
by unique events,
by annual offices,
or by royal life cycles.
So years could be designated
by an outstanding event
of the preceding
12 months, selected
and formulated by
state authorities
into long lists
of date formulas.
So from ancient
Mesopotamia, something
occurred, say, in the year
when King Enlil-bani made
for the god Ninurta three
very large copper statues.
That's how you'd give a date.
Or it could be dated by
the name of the holder
of an annual office of state.
So say, something happened in
the magistracy of Pythodorus
from Athens or in the
consulship of two named Romans.
Finally, and most commonly
in monarchic states,
was counting by the regnal
year of an individual monarch--
in the third year of King
Alexander, for example.
But each of these systems
was geographically localized.
There was no transcendent
or translocal system
for locating oneself
in the flow of history.
There was no uncomplicated
way to synchronize events
at geographical distance.
Two quick examples
to illustrate this.
One from the club of
Greek city-states.
The other from the succession
of Mesopotamian kingdoms.
This is how the famous Athenian
historian Thucydides attempted
to date the outbreak of the
Peloponnesian War, fought
between Athens and Sparta at the
end of the fifth century BCE.
And he's doing
his utmost to give
as precise a date as possible.
The Thirty Years'
Peace, which was
entered into after the conquest
of Euboea, lasted 14 years.
And the 15th year, in the
48th year of the priesthood
of Chrysis, and when Aenesias
was magistrate at Sparta,
and there still being two
months left of the magistracy
of Pythodorus at Athens,
six months after the Battle
of Potidaea, and at the
beginning of spring,
a Theban force-- a little over
300 strong and about the first
watch of the night--
entered into Plataea.
So this first shot of
war must be synchronized
to non-overlapping diplomatic,
religious, civic, military,
seasonal, and
hourly data points.
Another example,
which I won't read,
but it's from the
mid-sixth century BCE.
It's an inscription
authored or attributed
to Adad-guppi, the mother
of the last King of Babylon.
Sets up in an
inscription in cuneiform,
and it honors her devotion
to the moon god, Sin.
Text is on the screen, you
can read it yourselves.
The point is that Adad-guppi
calculates her 95 years--
this is the only way
she can do this--
by totting up the reigns
of six successive monarchs
from two different empires,
conveniently omitting the king
her son had murdered
to take the throne.
Thucydides' history and
Adad-guppi's autobiography
illustrate the complications
of pinning down
the flow of history
in the absence
of a transcendent and
translocal system.
Their dates are intimately tied
to central state institutions,
dependent on a
bureaucratic list making,
ascribable literacy
applicable only
within a self-limiting
geography,
and highly sensitive
to political change.
Indeed, they're not really
dates at all so much
as synchronisms
between multiple events
coordinating a network of better
and lesser known occurrences.
What is being dated
and what dates
it belong to the
same order of things.
Try to give the date
of, say, your grandma's
birth, or the invasion of
Iraq, or American independence
in this manner.
And then try to explain that to
someone from another country.
The founder of the Seleucid
Empire, a general of Alexander
called Seleucus Nicator,
changed all of this.
He introduced a new system for
reckoning the passage of time
known as the Seleucid Era.
This was the world's first
continuous and irreversible
tally of counted years.
And it's the unheralded ancestor
of every subsequent era system,
including the Jewish Era of
Creation, the Islamic Hijra,
the Christian anno Domini
system, and our own Common Era.
This first ever era was
never a regnal count,
never a count of Seleucus
I's years on the throne.
It's opening was
placed in 311 BCE,
over a decade after
the death of Alexander
when Seleucus regained
control of Babylon,
but six years before he
took the throne of kingship.
At his death in 281 BCE,
his summoned successor,
Antiochus I, did not
restart that calculation,
and all subsequent kings
continued accordingly.
So the date never
reverted to year one.
These two decisions-- at
the coronation of Seleucus
and at the succession
of his son--
gave the Seleucid
Era temporality,
a new kind of texture.
As we'll see, the era
counts was decoupled
from the phenomenal order of
things, objects, or events.
It did not represent a king's
reign or imperial office.
It was not dependent on
actions in the real world.
It was simply a regular
measure of duration
that rolled on and on,
paratactic, endless.
The novel texture
of the Seleucid Era
can be well illustrated
in a tiny cuneiform tablet
from Babylonia,
which carries both
the old and the new systems.
As an aside, much
of our best evidence
for Hellenistic
chronography comes
on cuneiform tablets,
which usefully combine
an imperishable writing medium.
So hundreds of
thousands of these
survive, with an obsession
with accurate dating.
The one I'm showing is about
the size of a smartphone.
The script is a mixture
of Sumerian and Akkadian--
neither language
spoken at this point
but preserved by Hellenistic
temple scribes, much like Latin
in the monasteries
of medieval Europe.
Showing two sides
of the same tablet--
could be obverse on the left,
the reverse on the right.
And you can see where a worm
has crawled through the obverse.
This tablet lists out the
astronomical Saros cycle,
that is, the 18-year intervals
in which a lunar eclipse takes
place on a particular day.
In its preserved
form, it extends
from the reign of the great
Neo-Babylonian monarch
Nebuchadnezzar II
in the sixth century
to the Persian
conquest of Babylonia,
the Macedonian takeover, and
into the early third century
BCE.
The text is organized
into three columns.
The right-hand
column simply repeats
in each row with the number 18.
That's the interval of
duration between the eclipses'
periodicity.
The middle column identifies
the king in whose reign
the eclipse series falls.
And the left-hand
column begins by giving
the regnal year of this ruler.
So an eclipse takes place
on this particular day
in, according to the
tablet, the 38th regnal year
of Nebuchadnezzar II.
Then 18 years later, in the
seventh year of Nabonidus;
another 18 years, the
eighth year of Cyrus.
These are all names to conjure
with from biblical history.
Note that the regnal numbers
in the left-hand column
go up and down dependent
on life cycle or conquest.
We passed through the
Neo-Babylonian, Persian and
early Macedonia dynasties up
to the third year of Macedonian
general good Antigonus,
the One-Eyed.
At this point, the
dating shifts from regnal
counting to the new
Seleucid Era system,
so I'm showing in yellow.
The right-hand column continues
as before to repeat the number
18 with every entry.
The middle column no longer gets
the name of a king but simply
the syllabic abbreviation "se".
And this syllable is
repeated without change,
despite the death of Seleucus
I, succession of his son
Antiochus I, death of Antiochus
I, succession of Antiochus II.
And in the left-hand column,
the year numbers of the Seleucid
Era accumulate irreversibly at
18-year intervals without ever
restarting or reversing--
15, 33, 51, 69.
Amazingly, for me at least,
when the scribe turned over
the tablet to write
on the reverse,
the calculations continue, but
the middle political column
is simply omitted.
So in the right column,
we have the continuation
of the 18-year periodicity.
And in the left, the
continuous Seleucid Era count--
87, 105, 123, 141,
159, 177, 195, 213.
I'm reading the
numbers because no year
dates had ever before approached
anything like this magnitude.
So what we witness on this
modest tablet, I think,
is a fairly stark visualization
of the distinctiveness
of the Seleucid Era vis-a-vis
previous temporalities.
We seem to be watching
homogeneous time transcend
the world in two stages.
First, in yellow, with the
use of the unchanging syllabic
abbreviation se,
which itself amounts
to an entirely new kind
of political abstraction
for monarchic states.
In a curious way, it's
the passage of time
which has become the
site of the immutable.
Then on the tablet's
reverse, in green,
we see the absolute autonomy
of the annual reckoning system.
And there's almost
a Jacobin logic
in this temporal technology
that can do away with a king.
This is temporal transcendence,
a universal, absolute,
freestanding, regularly
increasing number.
One last thing-- perhaps the
most important-- but also
the hardest to pin down.
We don't know when, after the
introduction of the Seleucid
Era, this tablet was written.
The Era as a regularly
increasing number
permitted an entirely new kind
of temporal predictability.
It had been impossible
for subjects of, say,
the elderly Nebuchadnezzar II
in the 38th year of his reign
to confidently and
accurately conceive, name,
and hold in the imagination a
date several years, decades,
or centuries into the future.
And this was equally true of the
other systems, the year names,
and the eponyms.
Now with the Seleucid Era,
this was easy, unproblematic,
and uniform for every subject
of the Seleucid kings.
One of [INAUDIBLE]
recent novels has
an image that I
think may capture
the force of this change.
And I do suspect it was
actually quite profoundly felt
and, in a way, unnerving.
Quote, "It was as if a
wall had been removed
in the room they inhabited.
The world no longer
enveloped them completely.
There was suddenly an opening.
Their glance no longer
met any resistance
but swept on and on
through more of the same."
All this would just be
an interesting aspect
of intellectual history without
greater social significance
were it not for two
additional factors.
First point.
The Seleucid Era was
only and exclusively
materialized as a
number and nothing more.
And dates had never
before been just a number.
So in whatever script
the Seleucid Era
number was recorded--
and we have it attested in
Greek, Akkadian, Phoenician,
and Aramaic--
the year's numerical value
was universally stable.
That's to say, within the
extraordinary diversity
of the imperial territories,
the Seleucid Era,
as a regular and homogeneous
cryptographic system, achieved
a regulating and
homogenizing force.
Second point.
The Seleucid Era
year numbers were
marked onto an
unprecedented range
of public, private,
and mobile platforms.
Era dates were affixed
to market weights,
amphora handles, royal and
local coinage, building
constructions, votive offerings,
seal rings, silver bowls,
royal letters, civic
decrees, tombstones,
tax receipts, [INAUDIBLE]
boundary markers,
astronomical reports, personal
horoscopes, marriage contracts,
manumissions, and
much, much more.
In a world of
ubiquitous date marks,
I think it's easy
to underestimate
the sheer novelty, and so
historical significance,
of this mass year marking.
But to my best
knowledge, this was
without precedent or parallel.
In no other state in
the ancient world,
in the Mediterranean
or west Asia,
did rulers and
subjects inhabit spaces
that were so comprehensively
and consistently dated.
In some, the Seleucid Era
proposed fundamentally
new possibilities and
problems of politics, history,
and religion with which I'm
wrestling in my book project.
It was a new temporal situation
that put enormous pressure
on long-held notions of
the future and the past
and, I'd suggest,
one that generated
new sites of contestation
between empire
and its subjects.
It's difficult to trace the
effects of this new time,
for only occasionally
will an ancient source
make its impact explicit.
Time thinking is
not so much a thing
that can be held as much
as a mode of existence that
must be inferred.
So for today, rather than
speaking in general terms,
I've chosen two
case studies, both
relating to the imperial
administration in which
this imperial time system was
translated into material form--
archives and market trade.
The evidence compels
only in its details.
We'll be descending into
the archaeological trench
to look closely at some
buildings, objects,
and their use.
These very humble remains
offer the only way
to begin to access how this
time began to pervade society
and with what effect.
I suspect that to
those who don't
deal in the ancient world, the
evidence I'm about to present
would appear
unbelievably scanty.
But they should
also give some idea
of our method and practice.
The first case study--
Archives.
The preservation of
administrative data--
tax documents, receipts, wills,
government orders, and so on--
have been characteristic
of complex states
since the Bronze Age.
And by the Hellenistic
period it had
been going on for many centuries
in the Mediterranean and Asia.
But Seleucid archives stand out
for the institutionalization
of this imperial time system
as the logic of administration
in sometimes bizarre ways.
Seleucid archives are
attested in one way or another
at a number of sites--
at Sardis in western Asia Minor
where I do my archaeological
work, at Kedesh in
northern Israel,
at
Dura-Europos-on-the-Euphrates.
This is a site
not far from Raqqa
and has suffered enormously
from destruction and looting
by ISIS.
At Seleucia-on-the-Tigris,
Uruk and Nippur in Iraq,
and at Susa,
[INAUDIBLE] in Iran,
and no doubt there are many
others to be discovered.
Less than a handful of
administrative documents
on papyrus or parchment survived
from the Seleucid Empire.
I think there might be three
from all the territories
between Afghanistan
and Bulgaria.
But hundreds of thousands
of such documents
did once exist, maybe millions.
These were rolled up and
sealed with a blob of clay.
And then this blob
was inscribed--
was impressed with inscribed
seal stones, which functioned
like authorizing signatures.
While the documents
themselves don't survive,
these clay sealings have been
excavated in the thousands
from Seleucid archives.
Each of these clay
seal impressions,
which are called bullae,
bears on its surface
the seals of public
administration
alongside personal seals
of the private individuals
who were engaged in the economic
activity once documented
within.
The number of separate seal
impressions on a single clay
bulla ranges from 2 to 40.
So some documents had, sort
of, 40 signatures on them.
In other words,
these clay bullae
trace the institutionalized
encounters
between empire and subjects.
Over half of them,
around 16,000,
prominently bear a
standardized impression
of a Seleucid Era year date.
The shape, size, and
content of the seals
are uniform across Babylonia--
ovoid impressions
with short sides
and slightly
curving longer edges
carrying a three- or
four-line Greek inscription.
So to give just one
example, the one in color
at the center of the screen,
the stamp's top line identifies
the sealed document, which has
now been destroyed, as relating
to the salt tax-- a tax on salt
[? trey, ?] [GREEK] in Greek.
Bottom line names
the fiscal authority,
the royal city of
Seleucia-on-the-Tigris,
on the river Tigris, which
I'll talk about shortly.
And at the center of the seal
in a much larger script is
the year number in
Greek alphabetic numbers
[NON-ENGLISH], the year 68.
And as I say, there are
about 16,000 of these.
The Era year number
is privileged
as the most dominant
element on these bullae.
By itself, numbers can
represent the empire.
These thousands of dated bullae
permit the reconstruction
of the bureaucratic practice
of this new Era time.
It seems that each year,
Seleucid subjects brought
their documents to the Archive
to be sealed and registered,
stamped in their own inscribed
seal rings, which usually
showed personal portraits or
family symbols side by side
with the Empire's year stamp.
So all participants
in this way were
pulled into the standardizing,
linear logic of the time
system.
Further, the number
and uniformity
of these clay bullae, 16,000
over 1 and 1/2 centuries,
required that the Seleucid
court systematically engraved
and annually distributed
year-dated sealed rings
to its officials.
So Seleucid administrators
received and probably wore
on their person these
Era dates populating
the civic and
domestic landscapes
with mobile, breathing
year numbers.
And, obviously, they would
need to be replaced every year.
The vast majority of
these bullae were found
in the Archive
building from the agora
of Seleucia-on-the-Tigris.
Seleucia was the earliest
colonial foundation
of the Seleucid Empire,
established and named
after the first
king, Seleucus I,
located just to the
south of today's Baghdad,
its outline and plan still
very visible on Google Earth.
It was one of the three great
cities of the Hellenistic world
along with Antioch--
another Seleucid foundation
in northern Syria--
and Alexandria in
Ptolemaic Egypt.
It was an entirely new city
conceived as a replacement
to ancient Babylon with
a rationalized grid plan,
policy institutions, and a
mixed population of Babylonians,
Greeks, and Jews.
Estimates for the population
ranged from about a quarter
of a million to half a million.
The Archive building at
Seleucia was constructed
along the edge of the
agora, or market square,
at the north of the city.
And it was a building
precisely constructed
to meet the new information
ordering structure
of the Seleucid Era count.
Seleucid's Archive
is the largest
known from the ancient world.
It's 140 meters long
by six meters wide.
I'm not good at
estimating distances,
but I think that means about
four or five times the length
of this room and maybe about
half the width of this screen.
Maybe.
The building had
a modular layout
of 14 identical rooms
linked to one another
by doorways and access, not
as is shown here on the sides,
but actually at the short
north and south ends.
And the wall niches
would have been
filled with bookcases giving the
impression of a long corridor.
More than 25,000 seal
impressions of documents
were found on the floor of the--
of these modular rooms
following a devastating fire
after the capture of the city
in the mid second century BCE.
While the bullae have
not yet been processed
in a way that allows
us to correlate
the fine spots with the
building's architecture,
it's hard to doubt that some
form of linearized ordering
was at work.
Certainly, the high proportion
of bullae with Seleucid Era
dates suggests that
this time system forms
the principal organizing axis.
At another Seleucid colony,
Dura-Europos-on-the-Euphrates,
one which has now
almost been destroyed,
it was a small little archive
room, which it niches,
which circles around
the walls of the room,
each one dated with a year so
that years cycled in order.
Just to explain the
photo-- at the time
when the site was dug
in the First World War,
archaeological photographers
used local workers for scale.
Right.
So the Seleucia Archive
building represents
a streamlined governmental
knowledge system--
a uniform, predictable
temporality
extended over a
defined linear space.
The combination of
dates-wearing officials,
date-stamped documents, and
dated-built infrastructure--
basically the correlation
of where with when--
represents a fundamental
simplification of statecraft.
This may seem natural or obvious
to us, but it was in fact new.
If I may reverse
Marx's famous dictum,
it's as if this building
were constructed by the bee
and not the architect in its
direct rendering into mud brick
cells--
the Seleucid Era's
underlying structure--
a single idea, unity
in construction,
and the linear repetition
of an elementary shape.
The Archive building
lined the Western side
of the agora for
about 140 meters.
It presented an
impermeable walled barrier
on the city's main
public square obliging
movement along its length.
Its external aspect was of
an absolute, unrelenting
linearity.
Indeed, the building's
very shape--
a long, document-lined corridor
without any real depth to speak
of--
comes as close as an ancient
monumental building could
to a simple line,
as if reproducing
in its public architecture the
serial, irreversible structure
of the time count.
Now we might be tempted to
think of archive buildings
as institutions oriented
toward the past as preserving,
accumulating, and even
arresting temporality.
But they were also, and I think
in much more profound ways,
directed toward the future--
directed forward.
The registration
of fiscal documents
was a responsibility
and a promise designed
to anticipate the
practical needs
of various legal scenarios--
inheritance disputes,
tax cases, and so forth.
More fundamentally, though,
the Seleucid Archives building
materialized a confidence
in the continuity
of the imperial project itself.
This vast building
140 meters long
must have remained mostly
empty for many decades
after its construction.
It expressed the inevitability
of a knowable, secure,
and stable future.
Put another way,
the verbal tense
enunciated by the
Seleucid Archive
was the future perfect--
this will have been.
The unparalleled enormity of the
building stretching 140 meters
into the future
was a translation
of the Seleucid Era.
It's a daunting spatial
gigantism and all
that this proclaim.
I find this building one
of the most terrifying
from all the ancient world.
There's something almost
totalitarian about its design.
I'll now discuss much more
briefly my second case
study, which is Market Trade.
Throughout the ancient
world, trade and commerce
were sites of enormous distrust.
It was competitive
in ethos, and there
were information asymmetries
between buyers and sellers.
Accordingly, it had long
been the responsibility
of civic and imperial overseers
to control and authorize
the devices of trade, like
weights and measures used
in the market.
This vesting of integrity
in the impersonal mechanisms
of commerce, rather than in
the face-to-face interactions
of fellow traders, was achieved
through visible guarantees
marked onto the surfaces
of trading standards.
These stamp symbols, or
names of civic officials,
indicated to participants
in economic activities
that a regulated system and a
unitary system were at work.
If, for instance, Athenian
weights and measures bear on
their surface the head of
Athena or a double-bodied owl,
Hellenistic amphorae from
the Island of Rhodes,
grain measures from
the Sicilian kingdom,
and other devices and containers
from many other places
carried the stamped
name of a magistrate--
the magistrate in
charge of the agora.
But within the Seleucid
Empire, this guarantee mark,
the symbol of official
fairness, was simply
the Seleucid Era year
number, either standing alone
or associated with imperial
icons or local magistrates'
names.
Got three fairly
randomly chosen examples.
One on the top left--
it's called a sekoma
A sekoma is a device
to measure fixed
volumes of liquids--
so four volumes of liquids
running along the top.
This is the front of the sekoma.
It would look, if
you were using it,
as if the liquids were coming
out of the lions' mouths.
It's dated to year 170.
Quite a nice piece from a town
called Maresha just southwest
of Jerusalem.
Very recently discovered in
building work in Tel Aviv--
a quite crudely made
handle of a jug--
of a jar dated to the year 158.
A lead weight from the
still unlocated city
of Demetrius-by-the-Sea.
It's a trading city.
Clearly, there's a
caduceus, Hermes' staff--
Hermes is the patron god of
trade, a dolphin, the name
of the city, and the year 159.
In other words,
the precise volume
of a liquid, the
carrying capacity
of an amphora, the
correct weight on a scale,
were all authorized
by the year date.
This number functioned
as a shorthand
for the entire system of
certifying bureaucratic
institutions and also for
the universal categories
of calculable and
exchangeable units--
perhaps the first example
of numericalized time
serving as a
commercial assurance.
These market devices guaranteed
by the visible Seleucid year
date, either with themselves
be regularly employed,
or would set the standard
for other shopkeepers.
In these ways, the
imperial time system
became the locus of the
conventions and categories
of fair exchange, of the
criteria of reliability
and credence, and,
fundamentally,
of political predictability
and accredited knowledge.
Most of these market devices
juxtaposed two measures--
the Seleucid Era dates and
whatever commercial unit
it guaranteed-- a liquid volume,
mean weight, silver value,
and so on.
Some kind of analogy
seems to be at work
here between a temporal regime
that, for the first time,
was systemized as a regular
numerical and countable
abstraction and those
sites and activities
where consistency and precision
of units were required.
Such quantification of prices,
weights, volumes, and now,
for the first time, in
years was a shared technique
of simplification, a
translation of the world
into a problem of arithmetic
in order to solve it.
This relationship
of analogy maps
on to a semantic quality
or characteristic
termed portability.
Portability describes the degree
to which a semantic technology
is contextually independent,
applicable beyond itself,
permitting one
domain to be treated
as if were constituted
by the same principals
or contain the same
features as another.
That is, time is like weight,
is like money, and so on.
And as we'll see, there
are contemporary hints
of such transposability
between the Era count
and standardized market units.
Now as Judy mentioned,
my investigation
of all this material is
part of the book project
on the emergence
and interrelation
of new kinds of time and
historical experience
in the Hellenistic east.
I'm interested above
all in the emergence
in the third and
second centuries BCE
of apocalyptic theologies,
or as I hope to frame them,
total histories.
These are texts that run through
a full and extended historical
timeline from the deep
reaches of the past
through a succession of
kingdoms or historical periods
into the Seleucid
Empire and then
to the predicted
end of time itself.
All our earliest
apocalypses date
to the period of
the Seleucid Empire
and they all emerge from the
Empire's core territories--
Babylonia, Iran, and Judea.
In this sense, the
end of the world
appeared for the first time
in the Seleucid Empire.
I think it's of the
highest significance
that these historical
apocalypses don't appear before
and they don't appear
outside the Seleucid Empire.
They're not found in
the Greek city-states,
in the Babylonian or
Persian empires, at Rome.
It's a phenomenon restricted to
the Seleucid Empire's subject
populations.
The theological and political
roots of apocalyptic are,
of course, complex and multiple.
And an entire discipline
of second temple
and early Christian
scholarship is devoted
to this problem of emergence.
Where does the end of
the world come from?
But the Seleucid Era
has played no role
in existing research within
either classical ancient
histories or biblical studies.
In my book, I'm suggesting
that the ubiquitous visibility
and bureaucratic
institutionalization
of an irreversible,
interminable,
and transcendent
time system provoked,
as a kind of reaction
formation, fantasies
of finitude among those who wish
to resist the Seleucid Empire.
That's to say, the only way
to arrest the open futurity
and endlessness of
the imperial time
was to bring time
itself to a close.
Further, that these
apocalypses answered
the monotonized, depersonalized,
and disenchanted, empty time
of the Seleucid Empire--
time that was a mere
passing, and so a loss,
with a conception
of temporal fullness
in which everything,
including the future,
was already determined.
Where all that happened
to you happened for you.
Where history was
shaped, directed,
and reaching toward
a conclusion.
And every event,
however dislocated,
part of a single story.
Above all, these texts asserted
that God, and not the king,
was the architect of time.
So in my closing
remarks, I'll try
to elucidate the unworking
of the imperial time regime
by returning to our
specific case studies--
market trade and archives.
The most familiar of these
earliest apocalyptic works,
and the only one I expect
people not in the field to be--
to know of is the Book of
Daniel from the Hebrew Bible.
The Book of Daniel was
completed in 165 BCE.
It's the easiest
biblical book to date
because it recounts a history
which is accurate up to 165
and inaccurate after.
It was completed in the
reign of Antiochus IV
at pyphanes, that is,
during the Maccabean Revolt
against the Empire,
still celebrated
in the festival of Hanukkah.
The Book of Daniel is built up
of two main sections-- a series
of court tales in Aramaic and
then of apocalyptic visions
in Hebrew.
But both parts of the book
display a subtle sensitivity
to Seleucid imperial
symbolism and, simultaneously,
a remarkable capacity
for ideological critique.
I'll focus here
on the famous tale
of King Belshazzar's
Feast, told in Chapter
5 of the Book of Daniel.
As the book reports, Belshazzar,
the last King of Babylon,
and his 1,000 nobles, and
his wives and concubines,
were making merry with
the sacred vessels
looted from the first
Jerusalem temple.
Suddenly, a disembodied
hand appears and inscribes
mysterious words on the
plaster wall of the palace.
Nobody can read them,
and there's general panic
until the now elderly
Jewish sage Daniel arrives.
He reads, "mene, mene, teqel,
upharsin", and then interprets,
as follows.
Mene-- God has numbered
[INAUDIBLE] your kingdom
and brought it to an end.
Tekel-- you have been weighed
to kilter in the scales
and found wanting.
Peres-- your kingdom has been
divided, or I think assessed--
[NON-ENGLISH]---- and given
to the Medes and Persians.
And that very night, the chapter
concludes, King Belshazzar
was killed and his Babylonian
kingdom conquered by the Medes.
The tale has been an exegete's
puzzle for over two millennia.
What is the connection,
it's been asked,
between the writing on the
wall and the fall of Babylon?
I think for our purposes, it's
key that the words on the wall
give the technical names
of market weights--
mene for a mina,
tekel for a shekel,
and peres for a half-mina.
And just to
illustrate this point,
this is a Seleucid mina,
the weight standard
from the market.
It dates precisely
to the time when
Daniel would have been
written, and it comes
from the vicinity of Jerusalem.
Daniel's own
interpretation of mene
directly links this weight unit
to the enumeration of time.
His interpretation of
tekel adopts the imagery
of a pair of weighing scales
to visualize God's judgment.
Like a shopkeeper's faulty
weights in the Seleucid market,
Belshazzar and Babylon had
been tested and found light.
So in sum, the famous episode
of the writing on the wall
pulls into a knot of mutual and
intertwined identifications,
market weight units,
the enumeration of time,
and the fate of empires.
And this is precisely
the semantic portability
that I think is first attested
in the Seleucid agora.
It's even more starkly expressed
in a passage from 4 Ezra--
an apocalypse first
composed in Hebrew
during the reign of the
Roman emperor Domitian
in the first century CE.
But in a passage that
cites a lost, probably
Hellenistic source
text, this apocalypse
has the archangel
[? Uranio ?] answer righteous
Jews, who are urgently inquiring
when the end of days will come.
And Uranio says, "When
the number of those like
you is completed.
For God has weighed
the age on the balance,
measured the times by measure,
and numbered the times
by number."
This is only one example
of how apocalypticism
engages with the Seleucid
Imperial thought world.
I think they're very
closely intertwined.
It's not simply
that the language
of Hellenistic
government-- in this case,
weighing and measuring--
is displaced to God.
Rather, it's the specific
material expressions
of the new Seleucid Era and the
calculative, authority-vested
time system these enunciate that
God's true sovereignty exposed
as hollow and transitory.
Something akin to apocalyptic
fantasies of closure
seem also to have been
enacted on the ground.
Back to Archives, briefly--
concurrent with the
large public archive
we've looked at at
Seleucia were a pair
of smaller domestic ones
designated by the excavators
as Archives A and B. Both
collections were deliberately
burned at the end
of Seleucid rule
in Babylonia preserving,
as elsewhere, the clay seal
impressions but
not the documents.
In Archive A, over and
above evidence of burning,
several seal impressions
of the Seleucid Era date--
these are the year
numbers-- were physically
gouged out of the bullae.
To quote the excavator, "There
can be no question but that
the sealings, and presumably,
the documents to which they'd
been attached, were
deliberately destroyed,
not for purposes
of cancellation,
but with hostile intent."
This was an effortful,
malicious act
that clearly went
beyond what was
necessary for the obliteration
of the parchment rolls.
A second case is a
little more gruesome.
The monumental
administrative center Kedesh,
located at the edge of the
Huleh basin in northern Israel,
had first been constructed
in the early Persian period
and was used by all
subsequent regimes.
Following the Seleucid
conquest and incorporation
of the southern Levant at the
beginning of the second century
BCE, an archive complex was
inserted into the building's
northwestern corner.
So this suite of rooms here--
and I'm going to be
focusing on this room.
We can reconstruct from the
small finds, topography,
and architecture of
the site something
like a fiscal route
of resentment.
The local inhabitants
of the region
were obliged to hike
up the steep hill
to the administrative
center on this ridge.
They would then enter through
this narrow door, pass
by (carrying their taxes)
a suite of reception rooms
where the local
administrators lived.
These were elaborate
mosaic floors,
imported gloss-painted stucco.
They would then deposit their
taxes in kind in the bin rooms.
And it seems that records
were taken of payment
or not payment, so debts
and preserved here.
So if you were to design
a building to generate
resentment, this would be it.
Excavation revealed
that the Seleucid
administrative
building fell victim
to two independent disasters
in short succession.
First, the site was suddenly
abandoned during or shortly
after 145 BCE.
It's about the same
time as the archives
were abandoned in Iraq.
Then the main archive room alone
of the entire administrative
center was deliberately burned.
Before the
conflagration, the door
was blocked up with stones, but
only at the bottom of the door.
So it seems more symbolic
than a practical act.
And then two infants
were buried within.
One burial had been too
disturbed for examination,
but the other was sealed beneath
a layer of burnt brick debris.
As you can see, the child's been
interred without grave goods,
and its head, hands, and feet
were cut off before burial.
This deposition was part
of the destruction moment.
It's not a secondary reuse.
The burning of archives was a
recurring, if not especially
frequent, event in antiquity.
But in our two Seleucid cases
from Seleucia-on-the-Tigris
and Kadesh, the destruction
seems to indicate an additional
and rather shocking assault.
The gouging out of year dates
before the burning of
the domestic archive
at Seleucia-on-the-Tigris points
to something like a symbolic
annihilation of the
administration, its date rings,
and perhaps the temple
system these manifested.
At Kedesh, the motivations
behind the horrific amputations
and perhaps sacrifice of
the child remain obscure.
Perhaps we're dealing with
a religious polluting, even
a magical unworking, of
the imperial Archive.
Perhaps it was an
archaizing act reviving
a defunct religious tradition
at a moment of revolt--
and there are traditions
of sacrificing babies
in this area.
But it remains unclear.
Notably, though, even
when the Kedesh site
was re-occupied by
later inhabitants,
this archive room
was never again used.
The destruction
of these archives
seems to me to be as
much about enacting
a temporal ending
as inciting a more
general bureaucratic amnesia.
And I think we can place the
symbolic undergound gestures
of termination alongside
contemporary apocalyptic
theology.
For each-- the Empire's timeline
is linearizable, open ended,
and pervasively
institutionalized the era
system--
was a provocation to finitude.
I don't think it's accidental
that our apocalyptic texts
adopt the archival
imagery of sealing a text
and filing it away
for the future
as their mainframing metaphor,
displacing once again
sovereignty from
the Seleucid king
and administration to
God and his angels.
This cleft door of resistance,
a physically violent,
disworldly confrontation
with empire,
and theological fantasies
of God's exclusive kingship
on earth recur in
various combinations
throughout the Hellenistic
east, especially as the Seleucid
Empire begins to crumble.
Let me close with some sweeping
comments which are really
provocations for conversation.
The Seleucid Empire was
not a timeless state.
That may be one--
surprise many of
the people who work
in modernity or early modernity,
but for the ancient world
it's quite unusual.
The Seleucid Empire
did not fashion itself
as archetypal or mythological.
It did not proceed
or transcend time.
Far from it.
More than its predecessor,
peer, or even successor regimes,
Seleucid kingship and
governmental practice
employed and encouraged
the dating of the world.
The Era was everywhere visible
as a basic and necessary
technology of administrative
knowledge and urban life.
By being exclusively
numericalized,
just numbers, the Seleucid
Era marked dates, not events,
and it was the first
chronological system to do so.
At the same time, by structuring
the kingdom's visibility
and institutions around a
continuous, irreversible
accumulation of years, it made
the Seleucid Empire historical
in a new sense, perhaps even the
first truly historical state.
This new imperial
time was just one
of the countless ways in which
we humans have comprehended
historical gyration.
That is, of course, undeniable.
And yet the imperial temporality
had also made visible,
at least in part, and in the
face of every cultural system
generated to deny it,
a terrifying truth--
the irreversibility, loss,
and indifference of time.
In doing so, the Seleucid
Empire made not only a new earth
but also, as I think we can see
in the emergent apocalyptic,
a new heaven as well.
It's in this sense,
in the tension
of living between an
empty time of state
and the core of an ending, of
balancing number with meaning,
that I think the claim
could be sustained
that the Hellenistic east opened
a very historical age to which
we still belong.
I suspect you're having your
own fantasies of finitude,
so I'm going to stop here.
But thank you very much
for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]